et d'ailleurs on en parle tout de suite
dans la revue de presse avec Bilal
tarabé
[Musique]
bonjour vilal bonjour Pauline la premier
tour de la présidentielle au Brésil se
tient donc dimanche l'ancien président
Lula reste largement tête des sondages
devant Jr bolsonaro absolument
libération qui titres en une alléluia
contraction de aller Lula et alléluia
alléluia parce que Libération est un
journal orienté à gauche et que Lula est
aussi un candidat de gauche ainsi
fallait le rappeler alléluia pour la
même raison mais aussi parce que c'est
une référence aux églises évangéliques
au Brésil dont l'influence sur la
société et les électeurs est immense
cela dit dans sa double double page
consacrée à cette présidentielle
libération s'intéresse à un homme qui
pourrait bien être l'une des clés de la
victoire de Lula il s'agit de son
colistier Geraldo alpine cet homme
n'était autre que son adversaire le
candidat de droite lors de la
présidentielle de 2006 et comme le dit
le journal je cite le spectaculaire
ralliement de ce ténor de la droite et
l'un des coups de génie plus là à le
secret vous découvrirez son portrait en
page 4 du journal autre scrutin décisif
sur le continent américain les meeters
du 8 novembre aux États-Unis qui doivent
renouveler une partie des membres du
Congrès oui et les scrutins se suivent
étant à se ressembler de plus en plus
sur le continent américain voire dans
les démocraties de manière générale
comme au Brésil on a deux projets de
société qui s'affrontent lors de ces
mitormes le parti républicain remania la
sauce Trump ultra-nation
ultra conservateur religieux contre une
gauche ou en l'occurrence un centre aux
États-Unis plus progressiste car pour le
journal Le Monde c'est bien la défense
du droit à l'avortement côté démocrate
contre les thématiques d'immigration
pour les républicains qui font la
campagne de ces meeters les tendances
donnent toujours les démocrates
légèrement en avance mais pour le monde
rien n'est gagné et donc ce titre
meeterns bataille acharnée entre les
camps les États-Unis ou sévi en ce
moment l'ouragan à Yann 12 mort déjà
recensé en Floride l'ouragan qui a été
rétrogradé en tempête tropicale se
dirige vers le sud-est du pays vous en
parliez et on a donc cette photo
extrêmement impressionnante qui fait la
une du New York Times c'est la ville de
forte Mayers en Floride sous les eaux
alors des enregistrements à filmer à
tout va sur chez nous à la télévision
mais aussi sur les réseaux sociaux on
voit que la photographie de presse
arrive toujours à capter l'essence d'un
moment et d'une situation en
l'occurrence cette photographie est
signée Marco Bello de l'agence Reuters
de la France cette fois le Royaume-Uni
ou la première ministre l'histoire
vendredi une réunion d'urgence avec
l'auber il s'agit de l'organisme public
britannique chargé de surveiller les
dépenses publiques après cette annonce
un du mini budget proposé par le
gouvernement de l'estros qui a provoqué
une tempête sur les marchés financiers
oui et le gardien s'intéresse au fait
que listroth a choisi les antennes
locales de la BBC donc vous voyez on est
encore dans les médias très 20 pour
annoncer enfin pour défendre son projet
de mini budget et ce que souligne le
gardien c'est que les journalistes des
antennes locales de la BBC n'ont aucun
intérêt ne passe pas leur vie à
Dominique donc ils n'ont aucun intérêt à
se retenir vis-à-vis de la première
ministre qui a eu donc droit à des
questions du type n'avez-vous pas honte
ou avait vous été ces derniers temps en
France la suite de la nouvelle affaire
qui secoue le Paris Saint-Germain
absolument libération nous rapporte ce
matin que deux anciens policiers et un
lobbyiste ont été mis en examen pour
entre autres faut et usage de faux
complicité de recettes de violation du
secret professionnel et là où ça
concerne le Paris Saint-Germain c'est
que ces trois hommes auraient usé de
leur influence pour fournir des
documents notamment issus de la police à
l'institution du Paris Saint-Germain
sauf que cette affaire en réalité de
volley puisque libération révélé hier
que ce même lobbyiste avait été détenu
et peut-être même torturé avatar pendant
plusieurs mois en 2020 parce qu'il
aurait eu aussi en sa possession des
documents compromettant concernant
Nasser el raifi le président du PSG et
le Parisien rebondit sur cette affaire
et titre réseau occupe du PSG les
suspects détenait des photos intimes de
Nasser el Riley on s'aperçoit que ce
trio se dessine si vous voulez le
scénario d'un trio qui d'un côté vendait
probablement des informations
confidentielles au PSG mais de l'autre
gardait des informations confidentielles
sur le PSG éventuellement pour faire
chanter ces dirigeants et d'ailleurs le
lobbyiste de son propre aveu un disait
qu'il avait été retenu au Qatar parce
que le Qatar l'accusait d'avoir voulu
faire chanter Nacer on est donc dans une
histoire qui sent beaucoup la
barbouserie chère Pauline enfin le monde
qui est rend hommage au saxophoniste de
jazz américain Phara j'espère que je
prononce bien son temps
qui est mort samedi dernier à l'âge de
oui alors ça n'était pas le saxophoniste
de jazz le plus connu du grand public ce
qui explique peut-être que ça ça
nécrologie comme on dit dans notre
jargon ne paraissent qu'aujourd'hui en
revanche il était connu pour avoir joué
et prolonger le message musical dans
géant du jazz celui du saxophoniste John
Coltrane et ce dont on se rappelle ce
que nous rappelle le critique de jazz du
monde Francis Marmande c'est que et bien
la vie de Pharao ascender se confond
avec la lutte pour les droits civiques
aux États-Unis il est né à Little Rock
en Arkansas donc la ville où pour la
première fois des élèves noirs ont pu
intégrer une école blanche et il a donc
intégré et porter ce courant qu'on
appelle le free jazz qui est un courant
musical du jazz intimement lié à la
lutte pour les droits civiques et
l'émancipation des Noirs aux États-Unis
merci Bilal pour cette revue de presse